oh wait let's get started so I was a
reminder for those presenting make sure
to hook the microphone to your clothing
rather than holding it so that the audio
is more consistent and we have two mics
so you don't have to yeah and we'll
start with this first paper hi everyone
my name is Alex this is soft backing
this is henrik and today we'll be
presenting a paper called made learning
of unsupervised learning rules done by a
team at Google brain about a year ago so
here's an outline of what we'll be
covering in the presentation we'll keep
it at the top right corner so you can
say oriented as to where you are so
first let's take a look at what
unsupervised learning really means so in
a sense unsupervised learning allows us
to learn the representation that will be
useful for further supervised tasks at a
later time and some of the most common
examples of those are variational
autoencoders which can learn a Latin
space representation of a probability
distribution so that we can later use
that for discriminative or generative
tasks and also cans which do something
similar but can be used to transfer for
example the style of a famous artist to
any given input photo but two of the
major deficits of both of these
approaches are that they tend to overfit
in a sense to that the data that they're
given so that they really can't
generalize well to other types of data
and that they require enormous amount of
more data to learn to solve another
problem another task
so this basically brings up the question
can we find some way to learn an
unsupervised learning rule that can work
well on a broad sense in the broad sense
a lot of given tasks and independent of
the specific data that they're given
so the approach of this paper takes to
solve this is something called
semi-supervised few shot classification
which means it's not totally
unsupervised but that it tries to solve
a supervised task using the most
efficient representation of some some
unlabeled data so what it looks like is
we're basically given some unlabeled
input as our train set and we try to
find some unsupervised rule to learn an
encoder that can then take this
supervised problem and encode the this
labelled train set in the most efficient
way to solve it so in this sense the
supervised part actually consists of a
small amount of data but it's more uses
of reference to make sure that the rule
we're learning generalizes well would
actually use it solving a supervised
problem so the question is can we find
an unsupervised rule that can work well
in a broad variety of supervised
contexts supervised tasks using Mayta
learning and before we do this let's
just take a step back and look at what
an unsupervised rule would actually look
like
so one supervised rule that we all know
well is backprop and what that does is
basically tries to learn some model
parameters by finding the changes with
those model parameters that will
minimize some loss function but here we
don't really have a loss function so
we're trying to find more of a general
rule that just given some made of
parameters and the last layer of a
neural network which is the architecture
that's kind of constrained in this paper
that we can kind of update those weight
rules automatically so like a lot of
metal looming algorithms this approach
consists of an outer loop and an inner
loop and the add loop is supervised we
have this what is kind of a loss
function it's called the mate objective
but it's basically the sum of the losses
for each of these supervised tasks that
it's trying to perform well on and the
inner loop basically gives the model the
chance
to go through lots of this unlabeled
data and try to make sense of it
basically to find the most efficient way
to encode this data so that it can
perform well on these later supervised
tasks so um let's let's take a look at
this in a little bit more detail this is
the high-level picture for how the
algorithm is going to work it has sort
of the components we're familiar with
we'll start with the inner loop so the
inner loop is what's modifying our base
model the base model takes in raw data
produces feature representations which
can then be used for classification and
this model is only so in this step in
this inner loop step we're only using
unlabeled data to generate these feature
representations and the task is applying
an unsupervised update algorithm or
function to change the parameters inside
the base model in the outer loop now
we're going to take this base model and
the feature representations that it has
learned to apply it on labelled data
generate a you know prediction for the
classification of that labeled data and
then compute the loss with respect to
the error between the labeled data that
we do have in the predictions from the
future representations and then that'll
be back propagated all the way through
through the unsupervised update so let's
let's think a little bit more about what
this inner loop is doing what question
are we trying to solve here well we're
given some encoder function which is
parameterized by the task specific
parameters Phi and the challenge we're
facing is to change the parameters Phi
such that given unlabeled data were able
to produce efficient compact
representations of that data and you
know it would be nice if we had some
true loss function which could tell us
how well that those feature
representations are useful for a
classification task but we don't have
that so the idea that they propose is
well what if we use another neural
network parameterize by the meta
parameters theta to generate those error
signals internally
so a little bit more of the mechanics
let's see what's going on here we're
gonna have this base model which is
parametrized as a as a deep neural
network with forward weights W for each
of the layers and we're going to take
our inputs pass it through the network
generate all the intermediate
activations and then at the final layer
output the feature representation of
that input we're gonna hold on to those
intermediate representation intermediate
activations and use them to generate the
error signals so these are these
intermediate activations are passed
through a neural network parametrized by
those meta parameters theta to produce
error signals which will be used in a
backward pass the way this process works
is you know at the top you initialize
your error with the output of you know
the top layers MLP and then we're going
to just back prop all the way through in
the way that we're all familiar with
we're at each intermediate layer we're
getting the top-down error signal and
we're also linearly combining that with
the output from the error producing
network so we can think a little bit
about how these updates are made now
that we have some way of producing
internally the error within the network
so Phi are the base model parameters
those are the task specific parameters
that are going to essentially learn how
to build a representation for yeah build
a representation of our raw data
those are parametrized by WV and all the
biases and then now that we've already
computed those error function or error
quantities we can make local updates
using just almost linear functions of
those errors there's some small
qualifications in that the actual
expression used to take in the error
quantity from the layer above as well as
your internally generated error and
impose some nonlinear functions on top
of it to basically normalize as it
propagates through the network so let's
let's think about what are the key
points to take away from this inner loop
process the first point is that the
error generating network is what drives
the
the unsupervised learning within this
base model and it's supposed to resemble
sort of what we're familiar with with
backpropagation these iterative updates
that we make using the backpropagation
like rule can be used to tune the model
parameters for some higher-level
objective that objective is defined by
the outer loop which changes the
parameters of the error producing
Network in order to have the
unsupervised training explore different
regions of it's sort of space of task
specific parameters there's actually
some interesting connections you can
draw between what's going on here and
say a reinforcement learning problem
where your task specific parameters Phi
are sort of like the states of your
state space and the outer loops role is
to define a policy parametrized by theta
which changes how your unsupervised
learning algorithm navigates its state
space and comes to a final sort of final
state which is able to take in data and
produce useful feature representations
of that data so now let's look a little
bit closer out what batter loop is gonna
do okay so it's it's all gonna come
together here in the odd row loop so now
where we're at is we had some unlabeled
support this was an inner loop and we
applied our unsupervised learning rule
which was parameterised by theta okay
and we'll hold off like oh how do we
actually learn say it up we'll get to
that so we have now an encoder now we
move out to the outer loop and we're
going to use this encoder so we have
labeled support so support is the task
specific trained data and the labeled
query which is the task specific test
data and we apply this encoder to these
vectors so you can imagine now we have a
bunch of images X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 that's 4
train images and we have two test images
and we're doing few shots classification
you
and we get compact vectors one for each
image if we're doing this under images
now we fit what they do specifically is
they fit a linear model for linear
regression on those vectors those green
vectors because we have labels here okay
so now we fit a linear model in just a
few examples and now we can apply this
model on the label query and evaluate
the model and we evaluate and get a mean
squared error okay now you have this
whole computation graph and to update
the theta in the top left corner we can
just back prop all the way through this
computation graph so now everything is
not the opposite direction and now you
may wonder okay but that inner loop it's
probably quite a few steps because we're
playing this on super these unsupervised
updates and yes that's like thousands of
thousands of steps many times so you
can't back prop through that whole loop
so what they do instead is try and cater
backdrop which I won't go into the
details of but basically what's going on
is the unsupervised rule does ten steps
of updating the encoder then we apply
the encoder fiddle in your model
evaluate the model get a mean squared
error backdrop and then we continue so
you do ten steps updates go through the
whole process back prop ten steps
update so that's so the spirit of
truncated back problem okay so how well
does this do
the meta train using cypher data and
emission F and then they evaluate how
well does this generalize to other data
sets what that means is we learn an
unsupervised learning rule we mental
learn an unsupervised learning rule on
Seifer 10 and imagenet and then we go to
another data set and see how old does
this Jim
then they explore how old does it do in
other domains and that means taking this
unsupervised learning rule that was
Mediterranean on image data and now
apply that to text data specifically in
this case and then they also explore
what if we apply this unsupervised
learning a little now to completely new
network architectures that that means
that the encoder has a different
architecture ok so what's going on here
we're evaluating our unsupervised
learning rule on different data sets and
compared to other methods I completed
three other methods but we'll only focus
on one other method right now so that's
a VA so it's an orange the variational
or encoder so in that case that you have
your unlabeled data you apply your auto
encoder get a representation in which
you do fit a linear model just like
before okay and then compare that to
their learned unsupervised learning rule
so VA e is an unsupervised learning rule
okay and but in where we're comparing
that to the learning rule that we have
learned and it does better on these for
image data sets tiny - reminisce tiny
fashion understand fashion ms now they
tried generalization over domains okay
so they evaluated the rule on two-way
text classification and if we focus our
intention on the purple the 30 hours
curve what that means is we did 30 hours
of meta training and now we have an
unsupervised learning rule and now we
apply that to their case of two ways
text classification and what you can see
here is if I apply my unsupervised
learning rule four thousand steps I get
a quite good representation such that I
can get this accuracy but if I apply my
supervised learning rule for a bit
longer for two thousand steps I can do
even better but then it levels off okay
so that seems to be seems to have a
learnt a use for a reputation for
textiles listen it's pretty cool they
there was no text data involved in
learning in this unsupervised on you but
then we can look at the two hundred
hours well this one represented I met a
train for two hundred hours got a rule
now I'm applying this rule this rule
doesn't work well at all and their
explanation is something along the lines
of in this case we have meta / fitted to
the specific images basically okay so
it's this rule here in the red it's not
as as general as the one in purple and
then they explore generalization over
networks okay so in the what that means
is so let's focus our attention to the
most blue one here okay so here's an
unsupervised learning rule that was
trained for 10,000 steps and then they
explore how old does this rule do for an
encoder when the base model has
different numbers of layers basically
what this says is it generalizes okay
that's well you can apply this rule
because this rule is you apply it you
can have as many neurons as you want to
or many layers as you want to because
this rule really operates on the neuron
specific layer okay and this light green
here it's just as a comparison what if
we basically hide is a random rule and
they try with number of units so the
first one was what's depth this is width
of the encoder and they also explore
what what if I have different activation
function in our
okay now let's finalize here with some
pre critiques and limitations
specifically that we identified well
first of all this is very
computationally expensive this is not
for you at home basically like this is
this took a long time to train and this
was after using many many tricks so what
one type of trick was just hyper
parameter tuning and gradient clipping
and specific learning rates but also how
the actual soup unsupervised learning
rule was parameterised and structured
was very tricky there were we abstracted
a way a bunch of details in this talk so
that was sort of also like a limitation
that it's that's it seems to be quite
hard to get this working and relate to
that is that there was no ablative
analysis meaning we don't know of all
these tricks like let's say there were
40 tricks in this paper probably there
like a pen that they were it's a long
appendix it's unclear what of what was
the secret sauce over what were they all
necessary or were some tricks more
important than others also
reproducibility like if we want to
produce this paper so many things that
we weren't able to actually get from the
paper for instance they're doing future
classification but how many label
examples did they have like what was the
K in there k shot and what was there n
in there anyway as well as how many
unlabeled examples did have a each task
that we were not able to read that out
from the paper and that seems quite
important to actually interpret the
accuracy scores for instance now given
these limitations we have some
suggestions first we could do a native
analysis perhaps this we were thinking
that in this case they're sort of doing
truncated backprop potentially you could
do something like implicit mammal
instead let us know if that's true you
could all say it'd be interesting to
investigate beyond just are then like
more network architectures such as CNN
or attention based models how a general
message to those it's their better way
like that include learning rule was
encoded in a very complex way like is
there a simple way of doing this and
also where we're curious like is this
learning rule fully Express this
approach and I think that was so if you
have any questions this is basically an
extension of matching networks to an
active learning case so I'll start by
briefly reviewing matching networks so
as Chelsey discussed in a recent lecture
one way to think about matching networks
is as a differentiable K nearest
neighbors over a learned embedding space
so in a very simple setup like we have
here we can imagine that we are going to
embed each of our example items as well
as our probe item using for example a
CNN and then we want to compute the
label for the probe item so to do that
we have either an attention or distance
function that
basically compares the similarity of
examples or embedded examples with the
embedded probe item and from that we can
take an average of the example labels
weighted by their similarity with the
probe okay so in the previous case we
had basically shape as the
distinguishing feature among the
examples but in this task color
distinguishes them so this motivates the
idea that we might want to be using a
context-sensitive encoder where the
embedding of a given example depends on
the other examples that are present for
that task so one way we might do this is
using a contextual encoder like a
bi-directional LS TM where again each
example embedding depends on the other
examples that are present similarly we
might want the embedding of our probe
item to depend on the examples that are
present so the way that they do that and
matching that works is they have an
attention LS TM which in addition to
conditioning on the examples also allows
the probe item encoder to do things like
ignore some of the examples if they're
like redundant or they're outliers
present and also builds invariance to
the order in which the examples come in
okay so that's like a bird's eye view of
matching networks but now imagine that
we're operating in a case where we only
have labels for some of our examples so
the area of active learning deals with
this because they're like lots of
real-world settings where we have plenty
of unlabeled data and then just a little
bit of label data or it's very expensive
to acquire so one example is like in a
medical imaging case it might be that
you could acquire labels for scans
through expert annotation but it would
be costly to get them so the idea
in the paper we're going to be
describing today is that they use meta
learning to active learn strategies for
a given task so in other words the the
model is going to learn which labels it
makes sense to request okay
so silly we'll go into the details in a
minute but just a high-level overview of
the model the idea is that we have a
controller and Alice TM controller that
requests labels for what come in as a
completely unlabeled set of example
items over a series of time steps so
this is the kind of active learning
phase and that means that at a given
time step the controller
you know sees its unlabeled set it
requests a label for one of the as yet
unlabeled items it reads in that label
along with the encoding of the example
item and then it uses this information
to basically make predictions for the
labels of the other currently unlabeled
items in the set it gets a reward for
how well it does and then proceeds the
next time step where it can request
another label at the end of T time steps
it takes all of the labeled items that
it's acquired and uses a modified
matching network to classify held-out
probe item so because it's making
discrete choices as it requests labels
this is trained with reinforcement
learning and the total reward is a
combination of how well it does during
the kind of intermediate rewards of the
active learning training part and how
well it does classifying the held-out
probe item one other thing to mention
here is you might ask like well why
aren't you using the matching Network at
each time step and the reason is that
the kind of intermediate predictor that
it uses is less computationally
expensive so it doesn't use the full
matching network on
probe item until the very end thanks
Catherine so now we'll dive a little bit
deeper into the individual modules used
in the diagram you saw in previous slide
and we also just had a picture up on the
corner just for easy reference so we
start with the context-free encoding so
these you can think of like for example
an image data you have a CNN generate
this encoding which is kind of
independent of the context of the
support set and then using these
context-free and codings we generate
these context-sensitive encodings by
essentially concatenating concatenating
these encoding together and then run a
bi-directional LST on that way they have
an idea what else is in the support set
then we have the selection module so at
each time step T we essentially get a
probability distribution over all the
unlabeled items and we have to figure
out which one we want to pick and so the
way we do this is we use a bunch of
different features the max min and mean
cosine similarity features between the
item in the controller item and the item
item similarities we concatenate these
all into a single vector and then use
the gated linear combination of these
features to figure out which which is
like the maximum logit we want to select
for the unlabeled label then in the
reading module takes this label and the
embedding for the item and simply
concatenate them together and then apply
as a linear transformation which the
controller then takes as input and then
applies a simple lsdm update like you
can see on the right there so and then
in terms of the prediction rewards so on
the top you can kind of see what does
the reward we're trying to optimize over
so essentially we want to maximize the
log probability that the label for the
held-out item is given given that the
from our held-out test item X and in the
current hidden state and the current
support vector at time T and so the
objective is to minimize this at each
time step and the idea we want to
maximize this at each time step is to
promote this any time behavior so that
even if you kind of stop Midway you
perform as optimally as you can but this
is quite computationally intensive to
calculate so the authors actually
suggest
calculating what they have on the right
which is an
mission and so now you can see there's
two reward terms the left being the
reward for the unlabeled items and then
the right being the reward for it the at
the very end across the whole episode
using the terminal support in the
terminal hidden state so on the left to
calculate reward term we can use this
mechanism which they call fast
prediction and essentially the idea is
that this is a tension based prediction
that uses these similarities between the
unlabeled and labeled items and then
they actually use this sharpening score
which they empirically found to work
much better and get better performance
and then the idea is that these
similarities since they don't change
with each time step you can pre-compute
them and therefore it's much faster to
use this computation then the slow
prediction which they use to calculate
the right reward term they do once at
the very end and this is using a
modified matching network which has to
pass through the full LS TM and it's
conditioned on the active learning
control state like H of T at the
terminal one at the very end as well and
so this is because you have to go
through the full lsdm this is why they
call it the slow prediction so just to
reiterate like the foil algorithm as
Kathryn was mentioning so for each time
step we essentially select the next
instance using our selection module then
we read this labeled instance
concatenated with the label and then
apply an LS TM update then based on now
the the labeled item pair we have we
update our known an unknown set and then
perform the fast prediction to calculate
that reward term as you saw on the
previous slide I'm at every time step
and then finally use a slow prediction
to calculate the right rework turn so in
terms of tasks so they wanted to
basically test out the strategy in a
couple of different tasks so they use
the omnibot which we're all familiar
with from our homework and so this is a
bunch of just characters from 50
different alphabets but they also wanted
to test in a more practical setting so
they tested on the movie lens data set
which is basically they just said
composed of many ratings by users given
two movies and so kind of like the idea
of this is when a new user signs up for
a movie
you don't really know their preferences
so how do how can you yeah this like
kool start kind of
thing where how can you figure out what
their preferences are so one example is
you can just show them random movies or
popular movies and see how they rate and
get their preference from that but
that's probably not the most optimal way
so this is why they use this active
learning approach in that case so in
terms of the omnibot baseline models
they used two slightly different
versions of the matching network and so
in the first one they use this random
set where essentially to generate the
support they randomly sample across the
images and classes so this means that
there probably isn't going to be an even
distribution and that even some classes
may not even have any images in the data
set for them to train on then the
matching matching that on the balanced
case is they actually ensure an even
class distribution so say five images
per class or something like that and
this is kind of like you know the
optimistic performance that you take you
would hope that the active learner could
kind of figure out to get as many unique
labels from each class as possible and
make sure that no class is
underrepresented or not represented at
all which may be the case in the random
and then the last baseline they used is
kind of a heuristic where it's like this
minimum maximum cosine similarity so
basically this is effectively choosing
items that are most different from the
items that you currently have so how did
this do so you can see that the they're
active mn network be the random one
which you kind of hope it would do and
then it came quite close to performance
into the matching net balanced which is
kind of like I was saying but you know
something that you hope the active
learner can learn so it's more of an
optimistic baseline you can see that
there is a two percent decoration on the
one-shot 10 way compared to the active
MN and the MN in the balanced case and
this is kind of expected because in a
one-shot case if you only have one image
and you're trying to distinguish with
you know a large n I guess many
different classes that can be quite hard
for the active learner to figure out it
needs to pick like a unique label from
each class and then as I was mentioning
before we wanted to optimize on both the
performance and data efficiency and so
in terms of data efficiency on the top
we can see the Omega performance and so
the left flotte is especially how is it
generalizing
a one-shot setting and so you can see
that like as you get more and more
labels requested the policy in purple
actually does much better than the ml
balanced case and the one-shot and
approaches in the two-shot and as we get
more labels it doesn't do better which
is what we'd expect and then on the
right you can kind of see how does this
generalize to situations where there's
more classes in the test set than what
was trained on so they do a comparison
with you know 5 10 15 and 20 classes and
then you can see even in the 5 class
setting it kind of it does recently well
it kind of approaches this Oracle policy
where basically requests a unique label
at every single time step which you'd
hope just look what the active learners
trying to do and we see that you know if
it is in fact trained with 20 classes
and that's when you test on it almost
matches the Oracle policy on the bottom
we see the movie lens performance so on
the y-axis we have the root mean squared
error and so we're trying to minimize
this and so in this case the active
amount MN actually outperforms all the
baselines and so the way they use these
based on so for example you have the
popular entropy so this is the kind of
what I was describing a heuristic like
earlier basically you just pick the
popular movies in your data set and kind
of show those to the users and so these
kind of baselines basically replace the
selection module in the network and then
they run the full thing end-to-end and
so this is kind of nice to see it kind
of gives you an idea of the importance
of the selection models the selection
module so you see the importance of you
know how you're selecting things in the
policy to do that and yeah so as you can
see it does outperform all these
baselines
so in conclusion they proposed a model
that basically active actively learns a
system end-to-end they showed that we
pretty much approach optimistic
performance on the Omniglot and we
actually outperform baselines on the
movie lens data set which is a more
practical setting so maybe that shows
promise for this work actually being
used in more real-world applications and
now I'm - Catherine will talk a little
bit more about their critique and
discussion points yeah so um we thought
one of the kind of most apparent issues
with the model
is that the controller doesn't actually
condition its label requests on the
probe item at all which is kind of
strange if you think about it so in this
kind of contrived example we've created
we have a marmot probe item and then one
of the other examples is a highly
similar image and you might expect that
you know you want to just request the
label for the other moment image given
that the other items are not at all
visually similar but on this model
there's no way for this to happen since
the controller hasn't actually seen the
probe item and that doesn't actually
come in until the very end of the
process there's a related point in
matching networks which is that the
embeddings of the examples don't depend
on the probe item so in matching
networks the examples depend on each
other and the probe item depends on the
examples but not vice versa okay kind of
stepping back though we were thinking
about the fact that active learning is
useful in a case where data is really
expensive to collect but this model of
course to Metalurh an active learning
policies has to have a lot of labeled
data to learn so we were trying to think
about domains where this would or
wouldn't be a realistic scenario and
we're curious if people had ideas
so I think one positive use case might
be like the medical imaging example that
we gave at the beginning where it is
possible to collect labels first scans
and maybe you already have a big
database of those but you don't want to
have like a label a label or having to
continue labeling scans in the future so
in that case you'd have the data train
the model and then you could use it
going forward yeah we have a few more
discussion points but do we have time oh
yeah and I guess kind of going forward
that like you know say you have like
these NLP tasks right so do you guys
think that there's this approach could
help in some NLP tests I guess in
choosing you know maybe more relevant
data or something that's you know I
guess more useful to the task
so I guess like one you know one idea
that we had was in basically choosing
the more relevant sentences so maybe
make a machine translation task you have
a bunch of different sentences in your
data set and maybe some are more
representative of you know what the
usual language is like maybe some are
more slang and you know depending on the
task maybe you want to pick the ones
that are more I guess more
representative or I guess what better
help in the translation and yeah I guess
like the last discussion point we had
was so they actually did a couple of
ablations at least for the Omniglot one
and so they found that the
context-sensitive encoder that we were
talking about where we have the Alice TM
run over all these contexts independent
embeddings actually didn't have much of
an effect are they and I guess like our
reasoning for that is probably because
in the Omniglot like all all the images
that you know CNN would probably do
pretty well I getting the context and
looking at what the other I guess
characters are in the support probably
isn't too relevant but maybe there are
other applications that you know say
there were different colors then that
would be really useful to know the
context of other ones maybe there's
other applications where this could be
essential so you like introduce more
variability like across tasks and the
example items you should expect a new
context more
[Applause]
hi everyone
is this working like so I'm Megumi I'm I
use I'm Tommy and we're going to be
presenting on one shot imitation from
observing humans by a domain adaptive
meta learning the authors of the paper
are here today which is great
so let's get started so let's start with
the general problem of imitation
learning where a robot must learn to do
a task by observing human demonstrations
so traditionally this is done either
through kinesthetic teaching which is
where a human directly manipulates the
robots arm for example or through tella
operation where this manipulation is
done remotely and in either of these
cases it requires a lot of grad student
time and effort to be put into this
tedious task of carefully manipulating
the robot humans on the other hand are
able to are also able to learn from
demonstrations by others but we can do
this through visual input so the
question is what can robots do that
there are several different challenges
with regards to this task so the first
one is that if we are trying to learn
from raw visual input that requires a
lot of data in the first place and
second there's this fundamental problem
of a domain shift so for one it's very
hard to learn the morphological
correspondence between a robot's body
parts and human body parts a robotic arm
and a human arm and this correspondence
might not even exist in the first place
for some robots and then on top of that
the robot must be able to generalize
between different demonstrators
different objects and different
backgrounds and learn tasks specific
parameters regardless of these other
changing factors so the authors of this
paper were motivated by these challenges
to
develop domain adoptive meta-learning
and here's the idea so the final goal is
for the robot to be able to learn to do
a certain task just by observing one
single human demonstration in the form
of a video so this is the end goal and
in order to do that we can provide the
robot with human demonstrations and
robot demonstrations during
Mediterranean where a human
demonstration d-h is a sequence of
observations and the robot demonstration
dr is a sequence of not only
observations but the robot state so for
example the robots joint angles or some
body configuration information as well
as the robot actions and so the idea
here is that during Mediterranean we can
learn how to infer a task specific
policy from a human demonstration by
validating on the robot demonstrations
which is much easier to do because you
have access to the robots actions and
this is just an overview and we'll get
into the details later and so just
really quickly this is very similar to
this is an extension of the mammal
algorithm so you can see that the thing
inside the blue box is the inner it's
what we would call the inner loop and
the red is the outer loop and you can
see that the loss inside the inner loop
is computed on just the human
demonstrations whereas for the meta
training part in the outer loop we can
compute behavioral cloning loss on the
robot demonstrations so kind of getting
more into what the algorithm is doing so
during meta training we first sample a
task from the task distribution and then
we sample a human demonstration
specifically of that task and then what
we can do is compute policy parameters
by using this loss el psy on the human
demonstration and during meta training
since we do have access to the robot
demonstrations we can sample a robot
demonstration of that same task and we
can update our meta parameters using
the lost calculated on the robot
demonstrations and it's meant as I
mentioned in the previous slide here we
can use LBC which is the behavior of
clothing loss since we do have access to
the robots actions and the output here
are two meta parameters so there's theta
and there's sy theta is something that
we are probably all familiar with so
during meta test time theta act as the
initial policy parameters that you're
doing the gradient step from and then
something that might be new and I think
there was a group that presented on
something that's similar to this is we
met a learn the inner loss
so there's else.i and we're learning
sigh which parameters is this loss
during méditerranée
and camille will talk more about that
later and then of course in the input to
the meta test algorithm we have our
single video of a human demonstration
which we want to learn from and the
output is the policy parameters which we
can compute from this learn loss okay
cool so we talked about the architecture
in detail so we talked about the
training step the meta training and then
also the meta testing so we'll go over
it in regards to this policy
architecture so as we talked about
initially what we have is this initial
parameter theta and we want to update
theta to be more specific to a new task
that we're trying to generalize to so
during méditerranée initially what we do
is we feed in this human demonstration
which is of a new task that we're trying
to update our task parameters to be able
to accomplish and so one of the things
that we think about is that as Megumi
mentioned earlier we don't have access
to human actions and they might not
directly correspond to robot actions so
it's not enough to enforce a loss on on
this action like the human demonstration
because that wouldn't give us enough
like we first of all we don't have
access to those actions and number two
since those since those actions might
not have direct correspondence it's not
actually going to inform us to make any
updates or supply any gradients to
update these task parameters so what
they do instead is that they have this
idea of a learned adaptation objective
and we'll treat that as a black
for now and then we'll get into it later
in the next slide so what happens
initially is we feed in this human
demonstration through some perception
layers so a few convolutional layers of
scribe - and then - of scribe one and
this outputs a feature vector which
corresponds to the perception like it's
it's part of the perception output and
then those features are concatenated
with the the last hidden hidden layer of
the control layers so these are the ones
that are used to predict the action and
we concatenate these two vectors and we
feed them into this learned adaptation
objective and what this learn adaptation
objective has to accomplish is it has to
understand based on this new task what
the behavior task specific behavior is
and as well as the objects that are
necessary to execute that task and so
one of the things that they theorized is
that to understand what this learned
adaptation objective should look like we
have to have a temporal view of the
human demonstration this is because
actions take take place across multiple
frames and having a view of all the
frames at once allows you to understand
what motions need to happen and what
needs to what needs to be updated is not
only the perceptual components of this
network but also the control components
because it's both the perception and the
control that influence the behavior for
the new task and so this learn
adaptation objective which we'll talk
about later is the goal is to supply
gradients back to both the control
layers and the perception components of
this network such that we can generalize
we can go from this initial theta to Phi
which is the new parameters for this new
task so after we update these parameters
we feed in a robot demonstration and
this robot demonstration goes through
the same perceptual layers and then we
have the robot configuration which is
the States so the joints of the robots
and the configuration of those joints we
take those along with the perception
features to predict the gripper pose and
the gripper poses essentially whether
the gripper should be open or closed and
so we have a squared error loss on this
to enforce that this that this is done
correctly and then because actions are
more complex than simply just opening a
gripper we have to have we have a few
fully connected layers which go on to
predict the action and then we have a
behavioral cloning loss based on the
robot actions that we also have access
to during Mediterranean so the
combination of these two things
does this one-shot imitation learning
such that we feed in this human
demonstration we have
one example of this and then we update
the layers such that we have this new we
update the parameters such that we have
this new five parameter which is
specific to that task such that the
robot demonstration can fulfill that
task so we'll go into this learn to
adaptation objective now so the way they
learned adaptation objective works is it
takes into account the perceptual
features that have been extracted from
those earlier convolutional layers as
well as the control the last hidden
layers of the control layers and so both
of these control the perception and the
control of the robot and what we do is
we feed these through temporal
convolutions so we we have one D
convolutions across time and then we
convolve this down using 10:1 D
convolutions and then lastly a6 1x1
convolutions and then we do a matrix
normalization to get a scalar value and
the goal is that when we update this
loss when we when we back prop on this
loss we compute this inner gradient step
it updates the parameters such that were
specific to this new task and then if
you look back at this behavioral cloning
loss that we talked about since the
behavioral loss behavior cloning loss
has this implicit loss that we're
learning embedded inside of this as an
inner loss when we when we do this final
gradient step on the behavioral cloning
loss it also updates the weights of the
side weights which are corresponding to
this loss so we learned this loss
through our meta learning procedure yeah
so now let's talk about some of the
let's talk about some of the experiments
that are being done that were being
compared to so the first one is the
contextual policy where all your feeding
in is the last image from a human
demonstration to identify the task and
the robot state the DAO CM policy was
talked about earlier but it's it's
basically you're giving the full human
video demonstration as well as the
current robot state to break the current
robot action and doing that over time
steps unrolling it da ml with the linear
loss is the same thing as what we
presented except instead of using them
temporal loss they just do a single lane
linear layer over the policy activations
and then DML two-port losses the full
network that we showed you before with
the full temporal learnt adaptation loss
there so just some I think it's great if
we can visualize some of the results
really quickly but the experiments that
they were working with
I'll change the speed so the first was
like placing and you can compare like as
you can see they're using different
objects and configurations at
Mediterranean medics has time and you
can see that models like the lsdm and
contextual model were not able to
perform nearly as well they've
misidentified the object or they were
not able to control even if they
identify the object correctly they were
not able to control the object they were
placing into the right spot and they
work with tasks like pushing picking
place and just place where the object is
already in the gripper of the hand but
qualitatively you can see a lot more are
struggling with contextual and LS TM and
linear lost is pretty well but not as
well as including the temporal loss
I almost maybe look at it breathe yeah
so picking places when you actually pick
up the object and also then place it
into the container so moving on to the
first experiment and really
understanding quality quantitatively so
the first one is placing pushing and
picking place using all three different
tasks but with all comparing the four
layers I mean sorry the four networks
and you can see that clearly the dip or
loss and the meta learned adaptive
objective was very useful and that
there's sick and an extreme increase
inaccuracies on all three of these tasks
so temporal information across the human
demonstration is obviously going to be
very important as according to this
table you can see the second experiment
was the pushing task so we're just
looking at one task of pushing but
exploring like the different backgrounds
that could be placed that you can use it
train it mediterranean meta test time so
in all these experiments like they're
varying the object from meta training to
met assess time the objects that they're
using they have different sets of
objects but now here we're really
focusing on background so using the
temporal loss the full model that we
were talking about earlier when it
operates on a scene background at meta
tennis time it has like any 1.8 percent
accuracy but on new backgrounds you can
see that I've significantly lower more
than 10 percent difference approximately
and actually what's more interesting as
if you analyze where the failures of of
the DML occurs on the scene in novel
backgrounds you can see that some of the
failures will occur from not able to
identify what the task is like not
knowing which like the visual features
like which object
place it in and some of the failures are
the second group of failures are even if
you know which object to place it in and
you understand all the visual cues you
can't control the object that you're
placing or pushing to move it to the
right spot so in a background that's
seen before you see that you have only
one out of thirty three failures and
task identification which makes sense
because you've seen that background
before but when you've seen new
backgrounds then you see a lot more
failure percentages in task
identification which is probably because
of the different visual cues that you
aren't used to and overall the failures
from control seem relatively straight
relatively constant across these three
background experiments and that probably
makes sense because just controlling an
object in different scenarios it's
difficult overall so should not change
much with the introduction of a new
background and a third experiment is the
third experiment for them in the paper
was placing it doing the placing test
but using the Sawyer arm instead of the
other robotic configuration they had and
the whole point of this was to test on a
different completely different framework
so this was like using kinesthetic
teaching instead of teleoperation for
the outer loss and you use a completely
different they use a completely
different robot here and a different
form of robotic demonstration so you can
see that there was still a pretty good
successor to 77.8% in placing so
basically what this shows is that you
can generalize the algorithm to
different robotic configurations and
different forms of supervision whether
that be teller operational or
kinesthetic and the final experiment was
really comparing the really
understanding the role of the temporal
loss and here in this experiment they
didn't do any domain shift it was on a
simulation robotic simulation and they
simulated the pushing tasks with again
like no domain ship so just really
focusing on the loss and you can see
that just using the temporal lost in the
meta imitation learning versus a linear
loss there was a large improvement of
over again like 13 14 percent so no
temporal loss is really important to use
to really identify the task and visually
use well
yeah okay so some of the strengths of
the paper so we'll go over the strengths
and then we'll do a critique also on
some of the limitations that we saw so
the success is that we can do we can
learn new tasks using this one-shot
imitation from a visual input of just a
human demonstration and so like we
talked about this is an extension of
mammals such that you can define there's
like this learned like with the addition
of this learned temporal adaptation
objective and so what they show is that
they're able to update these part of
these parameters which for new tasks and
they're able to do this with just one
demonstration of a human of a human
demonstrating that new task and that's
actually pretty impressive and we found
that to be a really good strength this
idea of a learned temporal adaptation to
incorporate temporal information to
understand behaviors and be able to
translate those to update not only the
perceptual components but also the
control components was also something we
found very interesting in a unique
contribution to this paper and one of
the things that we also mention is a
strength but we'll also mention later
again as a limitation is this idea that
we can perform well even though we have
the amount of data per task is low so
one of the things that happens is that
they have thousands of demonstrations
that they use during meta training but
the amount of data that they have per
task is actually quite low and what this
shows is the fact that they can perform
well even with having less amount of
data per task is that they can actually
generalize and adapt to a diverse range
of tasks which is also something we
counted as a string so to discuss some
of the limitations so one of the things
that we saw is that they have not
demonstrated the ability to learn
entirely new motions so one of the
things you'll see is that during meta
training and meta test time the
behaviors that you'll encounter during
Mediterranea are structurally similar to
the ones you'll encounter during
meditated test time and so it's not as
if you're encountering completely new
tasks that are structurally completely
different from those you'll encounter
and méditerranée and so one of the
things we thought would be very
interesting to see is how it would
generalize to entirely new sorts of
motions one of the other things is that
we need more data during meditating time
to enable and we're wondering if that
could maybe lead to better results so
one of the things that we mentioned as a
strength can also be seen as a
limitation in the sense that getting
more data per task might also give us
insight into how maybe even how they
learned at a adaptative loss can improve
on like motions that are more complex
and we'll talk about that as well
lastly we still require robot demos so
you'll see in meta training time we
paired the human demonstrations with
robot demonstrations in order to in
order to update these parameters and to
and to learn from new tasks so one of
the things that we were curious about is
since domain adaptation involves
generalizing from different viewpoints
different lighting conditions and all
sorts of domain shifts that might occur
can we do this simply with just human
demonstrations is it possible to have
for example maybe a discriminator that
can discriminate between varying
lighting conditions various domain
shifts and maybe send back like have a
gradient reversal later such that you
can send back gradients that encourage
an agnostic representation of some of
these things so this is something to
think about is do we need these robot
demos or can we do this even with just
the human demonstrations so some of the
discussions that we thought about what
we were going through this paper was how
do we interpret this metal learn
temporal adaptation objective so one of
the things that they show is they show
like obviously this metal learn this
metal learned temporal adaptation
objective is beneficial and it learns
important important semantic information
regarding how to update the perceptual
components and the control components
but it'd be really interesting to see if
we can visualize this loss in terms of
what it's actually learning if there's
any and one of the things that we leave
open to discussion is how could we make
this loss more interpretable and then
maybe how could this loss be used and
maybe other tasks that aren't robotic
space lastly can this approach be
extended to tasks with more complex
actions so we saw pushing we we saw
placing these are very simple tasks
obviously complex but like can we can we
increase this this approach can we use
this for tasks that might be more
complex in nature such that involve a
myriad of things to happen before the
task is complete so is is this idea of a
temporal adaptation loss sufficient to
be able to generalize to actions that
are very complex so that's something we
were also considering and so we'll leave
that open to discussion as well does
anyone have questions
you mean between this and just
substituting this with so I think what
what this learned adaptation objective
is trying to do is this idea of like
looking at a human demonstration looking
at like the like the actions that are
occurring across multiple frames and
trying to understand not only
perceptually like which objects in the
scene are important for a particular
task so this would be like identifying
the objects in the scene but then also
thinking about how to like update the
control layers of the network to predict
actions that can maneuver those for the
new task so I think this learned
adaptation objective is is trying to
look at that temporally and then update
these different components of the layers
I can I can see where like you could
update this with like some sort of
reward function as well but I think like
at least since we don't have human
actions or any sort of any other type of
type of supervision this is something
that's learned through some of the
gradients that get passed through this
outer objective as well to update data
so you can't discretize like the human
actions so that's why the last has to be
learned that's the main difference with
a standard represent yeah so this is
like implicitly learned as well so this
loss has learned during your
Mediterranean so since you're updating
these layers across time and then when
you do this behavioral cloning loss it
also updates science the parameters of
SCI as well so this loss is being
learned over time as a way to improve
improve this generalization to new tasks
[Applause]
all right okay
my name is Josh Melander I'm a third
year in neuroscience PhD student and
yeah I'm gonna be presenting on this
paper from Richards Emal's lab it's
called meta learning for semi super vert
supervised whew shot classification and
sorry remind me how long do I have like
15 minutes okay okay right so we all
know that recent years have sort of
ushered in this great success of
supervised class classification problems
this is you know sort of engendered by
this image net data set which is this
massive labeled data set but you know we
know that in the real world and you know
the way that humans get data it's it's
it's not this bolus of labeled data
right we have maybe a few examples of
labeled data maybe your mom tells you
like that's a tree or something and then
you have a bunch of unlabeled examples
so you see a bunch of trees when you're
walking through the forest and so this
is this is sort of the the problem of
semi-supervised learning and I guess you
know as someone who's studying
neuroscience I think it's a little bit
more interesting than pure supervised
learning because you know this is what
what biological systems are sort of
optimized to perform right so this paper
basically applies this new domain of
some I supervised learning to you know
this familiar problem of multitask
learning that we've been talking about
and right so to start off with the
familiar problem that we all implemented
a solution to in our homework you're
presented with a support set here we
have a goldfish and a shark and then we
get a new image and we have to basically
say which one is it right and the whole
point is that you know we need to come
up with the solution that general
- unseen classes now the the new twist
on this problem is in the support set
what if we're also given a bunch of
unlabeled data right so in addition to
the label shark and goldfish we have a
bunch of images of a bunch of other
animals and that that could include or
not include images of sharks and
goldfish right but the question is can
we leverage a can we leverage this sort
of massive amount of unlabeled data in
order to improve our our multitask
learning right so I yeah I guess just to
underscore this we would hope that
because we're seeing more examples of
images that we that we would be able to
learn something from that okay so what
does this actually look like in terms of
the task so at the top here we have our
support set which everyone's familiar
with and on the right is the query set
so 3m in three classes and we see new
examples of those three classes but in
addition we're also going to present to
our model this unlabeled data set and
here the the green pluses represents
unlabeled data that that come from
classes that are also part of the
support tests so right so we have like a
little finch and this this white dog and
a piano but then you can see there's
also these these distractor classes
which are labeled here with a red minus
sign right yeah and so so we have
training and testing and those classes
are disparate and you know one thing
that these authors wanted to get at is
you know not only can we leverage this
unlabeled data but the presence of
distractors presents kind of a
particular challenge for these networks
and there
try to present a way to overcome that
challenge yeah okay so this is just the
setup of the problem right and you could
imagine that there are a lot of ways
that you could go about trying to tackle
it we've seen a lot of a lot of
multitask learning and meta learning
solutions and I think any of these
siamese networks matching networks
prototypical networks any of these would
be fine starting points they the authors
of this paper sort of choose to start
from prototypical networks which I think
were presented on last week and extend
those models to a regime that would work
for semi-supervised learning okay so
just a quick overview of the
prototypical networks right so they
these are you know very relatively
simple models where you know each class
basically gets embedded into some space
and then new examples are then basically
matched via some distance metric to the
embedding of previously seen classes
right so in this case you know you have
a number let's say we have five classes
here in in purple and we're going to use
the scene classes to generate an
embedding and then new examples can be
embedded with that same embedding and
sort of classified based on its distance
to this prototype so this this vector
here this prototype vector is sort of
generated from from labeled data in the
sort of vanilla proto nets right and in
the original prototype paper and in this
paper the embedding is actually
performed with a pretty simple
convolutional neural network with three
by three filters Batchelor marie-loup
max pool and it results in a 64 D vector
so that's the sort of embedding space
right okay so you pass in a couple
images with known labels you compute you
compute your proto
pipe and then in the vanilla sort of
prototypical Network examples you pass
in your your sort of your query set and
just softmax over the distributions to
the prototypes and then you can back
propagate the loss through that
embedding network and that's really the
only thing that's trained is that
embedding right and so they they make a
lot of points in this and the papers
that it's it's a nice model because it
has very very little assumptions and a
very simple inductive bias and it's so
simple that actually in the case of the
Euclidean distance which they use in
this paper it reduces down to a linear
model so it's very simple okay so now
how do we extend this to the case of
unlabeled data and semi-supervised
learning so what they're gonna do is
here here you have an example the same
kind of embedding plot as before the the
dotted examples are unlabeled data and
the white examples are your testing data
so basically what they plan to do and
what they will do in this paper is start
out with the vanilla proto net embed
embed the embed the labeled data in and
get the sort of labeled prototypes and
then using the unlabeled data they're
going to refine those original
prototypes to sort of create new
classification boundaries and of course
this this will be sort of more and less
effective in the cases where you have
distractors and so we'll talk a little
bit about how they deal with that okay
so so you start with the labeled data
that you're passing in and you're going
to generate the labeled prototypes but
via the embedding which is just the mean
of your embedding for all of all of your
examples and then for each of the
unlabeled inputs you're going to give
them a partial assignment to each
cluster using some distance metric and
then incorporate those
labeled data into the original prototype
and now you have a new prototype that
has incorporated the unlabeled data and
this is very simple and done using sort
of soft k-means which is differentiable
k-means right so basically if we have
this unlabeled support set that we're
also passing in with the labeled the
labeled support set then what we can do
is sort of assign each of these
unlabeled data sets or each each of
these unlabeled data points to one of
the classes this is just sort of a soft
max on the on the distance of the
unlabeled data to each of the original
prototypes and then incorporate that
into our new prototype so this is it's
just the prototypical networks what
they're performing k-means on the
unlabeled data and using that to update
their new prototypes right so yeah as I
mentioned this sort of breaks when you
think through the logic when you
incorporate a distractor class and
that's because you don't want to be
incorporating distractor classes into
your updated prototypes so they offer
two solutions for this the first is to
just add another prototype at the origin
so 0 0 0 out to 64 and this is just kind
of like a buffer to capture all of the
distractions but this sort of relies on
this assumption that all of the
distractors are coming from one class
which we know is not going to be the
case right you see lots of different
classes that are confounding your
inferences not just just one right so to
to deal with this they come up with a
also pretty simple strategy where they
they do their soft means prototype
update on the unlabeled data and then
they also have a small 20 neuron 20
neuron wide single layer neural network
that basically takes in the distance to
some some sort of computed distance to
six so the min/max variant scheme Kurt
of each image to each class and it's
going to take these in and basically
give a threshold to each prototype so
yeah so now they have a differentiable
way to to sort of set boundaries on how
aggressively the prototype should be
taking in the unlabeled data right and
it's differentiable so they can just
train this end-to-end and I'll come back
to this in a bit but it turns out to be
quite useful okay so so that's the
general strategy they have this this
original proto met with k-means and in
order to deal with the distractor
classes they have a little neural
network that will basically tell you how
aggressively to incorporate the
unlabeled data now they they test these
results on the Omniglot data set as well
as the mini imagenet data set however
they also generate this new split of
imagenet which they call tiered imagenet
and they they seem to make a big deal
about it in the paper but the idea is
that it's sort of more organized based
on higher nodes in the sort of semantic
classification of the network so whereas
in mini imagenet you have electric
guitars and testing and acoustic guitars
and training and the tiered imagenet
it's sort of more diverse so your
testing has musical instruments and your
training has farming equipment so you're
actually seeing completely unseen
classes of images and basically across
the board they're gonna take 10% of of
their training split for labeled data
and ninety percent goes to unlabeled
classes and so it's important to point
out that because they're only labeling
10% of the data they're actually getting
there so using much much less labels
than sort of all of the previous work
that we've been talking about and all of
the results that I'm going to show you
they are using it's basically a five-way
classification
and they are including five five
unlabeled examples as well and in the
case of distraction they're going to be
including five unlabeled images from
distractor classes as well okay so a
couple baselines before I show you the
results so first they just have the
vanilla proto net so ignore the the
unlabeled classes and just just do the
proto net thing and then the second is a
sort of semi-supervised inference so
this is the vanilla proto net the
embedding generated from the vanilla
proto net but now they're actually doing
the k-means during training so this is a
way to test how much the embedding is is
changing with the unloved labeled data
and they find that they're able to get
sort of unsurpassed accuracy with their
k-means clustering on the proto net as
well as the sort of this masked neural
network version of the k-means proto
nets and on the on the left is just with
unlabeled data from the same classes on
the right you have unlabeled data with
distractors and what they find is that
across the board the sort of masked
k-means proto nets do the best and
especially they do the best across all
three data sets in the distractor cases
so yeah there's a few other baselines
they look at just like a linear
regression and sort of a one-way k-means
with just the pixels and but I I'm
running out of time so I guess the last
sort of novel thing that they found is
that you know if you if during the
training if you now so you've trained
this network to embed and now during
testing you're going to increase the
amount of unlabeled data and what they
find is that as you start increasing so
you've frozen the network you no longer
gradient updates but as you start
increasing the amount of unlabeled data
the model starts to sort of outperform
the classic proto in that example so
what they're claiming here is that these
models learn to generalize from
unlabeled data in other words you
basically you would imagine that their
performance would increase as you took
the number of unlabeled examples and
distractors out to infinity and that's
what they show here and then they also
sort of make a point about the fact that
they have this disc you can really start
to separate the models in the distractor
case with the generalization okay so
right they achieve state-of-the-art
performance over a couple logically
proposed baselines on the three data
sets this k-means masked model performs
best with the distractors and they also
show that their models are able to
extrapolate to sort of make make more
efficient use of new unlabeled data and
not that interesting that they also
proposed this sort of new benchmark data
set of this tiered image net a few
critiques I didn't have a lot of sort of
nitpicky critiques I think it was a
relatively straightforward application
of this previous work from proto nets
and you know the beloved k-means
clustering so they it makes sense to use
them and and it worked
I think you know they they chose this
Prater net model and they claimed that
the reason they wanted to do this was
because it had very simple inductive
bias but it's not really clear exactly
what they gained from that because they
didn't actually do any anything that
required having a very interpretable
model and also I compared to some of the
other methods that everyone's presented
I think this this particular approach
doesn't really generalize very well
beyond classification problems yeah so I
guess future directions I would be
pretty interested to take this case to
the next extreme which is now you don't
have any labeled data and so you're
you're just presented with images
without labels and you have to sort of
figure out which images which new query
images correspond to which unlabeled
support images and right and so then the
model would need to not only learn how
many classes there were but also to
correctly classify them I think that
there's some pretty straightforward
applications of some some work done here
in the Bay Area sort of looking at
unsupervised representations between
images so yeah it would be cool to apply
that here yeah that's a pretty simple
paper questions no okay yeah so in so
it's this Stella you this paper is is
pretty cool and you should check it out
if you're not familiar but they
basically the idea is like you can pass
in image net with without labels and
they have this sort of embedding
strategy where you can embed each image
into this 128 D unit sphere and
basically from that without labels learn
the learn how many classes there are
based on the sort of differences between
images and between classes right so it's
it's like a way of creating an embedding
space that separates out different
classes based on the sort of variability
between between examples of the same
class
in a way that's completely unsupervised
so no labels and yeah and
ten classes yes just for each class come
up with five subclass item step out how
can you learn anything general without
having any classes how can you learn
anything without yeah I could go in now
and say no actually this day has 20
classes like number of classes that you
serve as a human in a way yes yeah yeah
no I think that's a I think that's a
good point other than the fact that
there is something objective you know
that there is something objective in
that these are examples of specific
classes of things and like each class
has its own set of like its own
distribution of relationships within a
class yeah it's yeah I think that's
that's that's sort of more of a critique
on on this work and but but yeah it's a
good point yeah yeah thanks